hi teachers this is Sal Khan here from
Khan Academy and welcome to course
mastery so back in 1984 famous education
researcher Benjamin bloom published the
famous to sigmah study where he showed
that a student who works in a mastery
learning framework with a tutor
one-on-one can operate two standard
deviations better so the student who is
operating the 50th percentile can
operate well into the 90th percentile
95th 96 percentile you fast forward to
today they've been over 200 studies that
have backed up his claims on top of that
you as an educator know that your
students enter your class at all
different levels you also know that
differentiation has always been
considered a best practice in education
the hard part however is how do you do
that with 25 30 35 kids in the classroom
all of us at Khan Academy we firmly
believe that if we had to pick between
an amazing teacher and an amazing
technology we'd pick you every time the
amazing teacher luckily we don't have to
make that trade-off and so we're
thinking about how can we empower you an
amazing teacher with as powerful
technology as possible and that's what
course mastery is it's a way for you to
set mastery goals for your students and
these goals are fairly large goals so
they'd be appropriate for over a term or
over a school year and you set it once
and then you can feel confident that
over the rest of the year or the rest of
the term your students have things to
work on that are appropriate for them
they'll be able to learn at their own
time and pace master concepts at their
own time and pace consistent with
Benjamin blooms work and remediate their
gaps is necessary and multiple studies
have shown that when students on Khan
Academy are able to engage in mastery
learning learn at their own time and
pace for even 30 minutes or more per
week so say 45 minutes a week or one
class period a week they're able to
accelerate their learning as measured by
standardized benchmark exams by twenty
or thirty percent